vamos a temas de salud y con más Romero
sala Buen día para usted Mar buenos días
Ángela y me encanta su tema de hoy
Muchas gracias con enfoque de género el
11 de febrero se celebra el Día
Internacional de la mujer y de la niña
en la ciencia un campo donde todavía y
diría que yo por mucho se vive en
desigualdades por supuesto existen hoy
en día existían en el pasado y seguro
van a seguir existiendo durante un
tiempo Quién hace la ciencia importa
mucho en todos los ámbitos sabemos que
todos tenemos sesgos Incluso en un campo
como la ciencia o la salud que muchas
veces se jacta de ser tan objetiva por
ejemplo elegir qué se estudias en uno de
los sesgos donde más se ve estas
diferencias de género así que cualquier
mirada que se salga de lo tradicional
masculino incluso que se salga de lo
binario en el que vamos a basar
Igualmente toda esta Crónica tiene
muchísimo que aportar hay muchos
ejemplos por ejemplo en el campo de la
prehistoria está cenada se pensaba que
las mujeres nunca eran cazadoras Eso se
desmontó especialmente en 2020 a través
de unos restos que se encontraron que
desmentían esas afirmaciones en el campo
de la salud que Pues apela aquí en esta
Crónica sabemos muy poco por ejemplo
sobre los cuerpos fisiológicos de las
mujeres sobre sus cambios hormonales hay
una tradición de subestimar su dolor
también muchísimas veces o incluso en
enfermedades no las diferencias en los
síntomas de algunas enfermedades como se
presentan en cuerpos femeninos o
masculinos no se ha estudiado suficiente
Y eso pues todavía hoy en día sigue
teniendo consecuencias sobre nuestra
salud y cómo iba a ser si todos los
modelos que se utilizan son de hombres
exactamente ahora los sesgos empiezan
para nosotras desde muy temprana edad si
la infancia es un momento clave al final
para desarrollar nuestros intereses no
luego se puede traducir en qué vamos a
estudiar o en qué vamos a trabajar y hay
un estudio publicado por la revista
Science en 2017 que medía la percepción
de los niños y de las niñas sobre sus
propias características no de su propio
género los niños puntuaban niños las
niñas puntuaban niñas y por ejemplo se
veía que en abrillantez digamos o en
genialidad en inteligencia en los cinco
años todavía había una percepción pues
parecida pero a partir de los cinco años
los niños empezaban a percibirse mucho
más inteligentes que las propias niñas a
ellas mismas mientras que en amabilidad
no o en la capacidad de cuidar también a
los 5 años todavía era más o menos
parecido a partir de ahí las niñas
empiezan a percibir como mucho más
amables o tranquilas que los propios
niños y nunca es tarde para recordar que
no hay ningún motivo biológico o
científico Que expliqué que las mujeres
o las niñas sean más cuidadosas o
amables que los niños y que los niños
sean más inteligentes Esto está basado
al final en una percepción o social en
un constructo social que nos rodea Y esa
misma inteligencia nos lleva a pensar
que los más inteligentes son los que
pueden estudiar por ejemplo ciencias
exactas no Así es exactamente Y eso
influye mucho en este Paso como decíamos
a la carrera profesional buscamos datos
oficiales en este caso de España y
además es interesante porque se empieza
a ver una diferencia En qué tipo de
ciencia estudian las mujeres incluso
cuando deciden si lanzarse o estudiar en
la ciencia por ejemplo la línea que está
más abajo está línea vino tinto es la
línea de ingeniería y arquitectura menos
del 30% de las mujeres que es de las
personas Perdón que estudian estas
carreras son mujeres en cambio en
ciencias de la salud son el 70% de la
facultades de ciencias de la salud en
España el 70% son mujeres y eso pues
como veíamos nos habla también de ese
tipo de ciencias que eligen no de que
las mujeres están incorporando a
estudiar estas carreras desde hace años
pero que también estas sesgos de género
influyen en esto las matemáticas la
física la ingeniería se percibe de hecho
esto lo decía un estudio de la UNESCO en
2019 se percibe como que se necesita una
inteligencia o una genialidad innata
como decías las ciencias exactas
mientras que la salud o incluso las
ciencias ambientales están más vistas
como algo que requiere esfuerzo y no
solo pues inteligencia Y que además
tiene un componente muy claro de cuidar
al resto de tener un impacto en la
sociedad y de interactuar con personas
puros estereotipos más mujeres
estudiando
se traducen más mujeres investigando y
aún hay una brecha gigante en ese tema
por supuesto y como decíamos son cambios
al final que van avanzando
generacionalmente que es difícil medir
actualmente no solo como una medida
única sino que en el tiempo seguro va a
ir mejorando Como tantas otras cosas y
Vamos a repasar para eso los datos de la
UNESCO también para América Latina
Cuántas mujeres se dedican a la
investigación por ejemplo más del 60% en
Venezuela importante destacar que eran
datos de 2016 esto pues puede haber
cambiado bastante hay varios países que
rondan el 50% no alrededor de la paridad
Pero hay muchos que no llegan ni al 40
estamos hablando de Colombia chile
México también Perú no Y además no es
solo incluso la cifra absoluta de
Cuántas mujeres están haciendo
investigación sino también que hay
muchas diferencias a medida que se
Avanza en la carrera profesional no a
medida que ocupan cargos de más poder
por ejemplo llegar a catedráticas se ve
que también cada vez son menos se van
difuminando esa presencia de las mujeres
a medida que se avanzan en esas
posiciones de poder o laborales por
ejemplo los cargos directivos de los
hospitales es decir que todavía hay
mucho camino por recorrer pero no ve que
nos están diciendo desde que somos niñas
que nos toca cuidar a los bebés cuando
crezcamos claro Entonces desde hoy nos
toca empezar a influir en las niñas para
que no nos rezamos gracias a usted más
gracias Ángela